Another Thing That Doctor Bright Is Not Allowed
To Do At The Foundation: SCP-963 is not to
be used for recreational or procreational
purposes.
Well, uh, this one leaves a frightening amount
open to interpretation.
SCP-963 is Dr. Bright’s medallion which
houses his consciousness and can pass it on
to others.
If ever it remains connected to one body for
over thirty days, it leaves a permanent copy
inside the body, meaning Dr. Bright could
theoretically make clones of himself.
He’s generally not allowed to do the latter
under any circumstances, but especially if
the plan is to, say, use the copy to do menial
chores or stand in for him at more boring
meetings while Dr. Bright plays solitaire
in his office.
And they definitely wouldn’t tolerate Dr.
Bright committing any…
Um…
Onanism…
With his clones, thank you very much.